the little people of america have more
clout than all of native americans
because like redskins they're just like
we're not changing them man yeah yeah
yeah
when in fact on opening day we're gonna
bring out some native americans we'll
pay them some money put them in chiefs
jerseys or whatever
yeah yeah yeah and say no we're cool
with it
before they even consider changing it
right we'll have we'll we'll have chief
wahoo
yeah from the cleveland indians yeah
who's just a white guy
who's like riding a horse out there i
love chief wahoo though i'm a big fan of
chief wahoo
really you know the guy no i don't know
the guy but i'm saying like the indians
you know why they're called the indians
i'm gonna nerd out i love baseball
because it's from indiana nope
the good guess though cleveland no they
were they were called
the cleveland spiders and then they get
they had like the first ever native
american on the baseball team oh wow
and then one and then they got a they
got like a second native american they
were only they were the only team that
had like two native americans
and so one of the guys on the cleveland
india on the cleveland spiders at the
time
goes man we should start calling
ourselves the cleveland indians he's
like basically razz and his teammates
yeah and they were like yeah it'd make
us look super
progressive like it'll be good so they
so they literally started
calling them the cleveland indians they
changed the team name and the original
chief wahoo was actually
he looked a little less racist he kind
of looked like one of these simpsons
guys he was like a yellow-faced chief
wahoo
and that's the thing is uh judd apatow
is that great joke they did on the
tonight show he's like any drawing of a
jewish person is inherently
anti-semitic yeah because like if i hand
you a paper said draw a jewish person
and then you hand it back to me it's
gonna look pretty offensive right right
because you're trying to draw the
attributes of the person
same thing happened with this they said
draw an indian and the guys are yeah
they're cartoonists here scroll down you
can see that
yeah the original chief wahoo he was
kind of yellow and then they had to like
redo it because native americans and
people were very upset but look at the
new one
the new one they just gave him veneers
made him red
they made him yeah chief and also chief
wahoo is supposed to mean like
celebrating indians like wahoo
we're celebrating so it's all well
intentioned i say like all the indian
stuff is pretty well intentioned
it just amazed me that they changed the
name to the cleveland indians after they
had two
indian players like can you imagine if
but that's kind of nice though when you
think about it yeah they thought they
were doing like a funny cool thing
yeah but like just imagine if all teams
did that like when jackie robinson
first went on the dodger that's like no
we're not the dodgers anymore we're the
and then you say something jackie dude
the atlanta
crackers and that was a negro league's
team really the atlanta crackers oh
that's hilarious
oh they were called the atlanta black
crackers oh the black crackers wait
because they were kind of saying like
we're like a team of white boys i don't
know if that's how that worked but they
were the
uh there you go the atlanta crackers
played first in the southern association
game uh baseball 1902.
yeah and i don't know if that's i don't
know why they were called that but
i think the origins of the team name is
unknown but there was a there if you go
to the negro league museum
uh which is great it's awesome right by
the jazz museum i don't even have time
for the jazz museum because i just they
thought i was patronizing them
where in cleveland no the [ __ ] league
museum is in kansas city
yeah it is awesome awesome yeah and i
stayed over there so much because i just
love baseball so much
and they were like they thought i was
mocking them they're like nobody likes
it this much like this guy's been in
there for like six hours i like watched
everything i read everything yeah i know
all this crap but
um but yeah they were called the atlanta
the atlanta crackers and i think that
they were doing that as like a
like an fu to the white league like all
right well it could be the crackers
because when i saw that uh high school
was called the fighting midgets i'm like
i want a t-shirt yeah it's cool
like i don't i i don't want you to shut
down if the intentions are good i think
yeah that's that's how i measure it not
everyone imagines that good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one